c'est indique par exemple que nous
ferons conduit à fixer une heure de
printemps mineurs dictée pour mieux
faire coïncider le jour et la journée
1973 c'est l'année du premier choc
pétrolier les prix du pétrole flambe
il faut faire des économies d'énergie
pour réduire l'éclairage en soirée
valéry giscard d'estaing alors ministre
de l'économie
décide d'instaurer l'heure d'été dès
mars 1976
le changement d'horaire connaissait ses
56 par quoi a décalé d'une heure je ne
comprenais à 2 heures du matin il sera 3
heures à l'origine la mesure n'est que
provisoire il ne fait pas que des
heureux
certains francis s'en moque même
totalement comme sur l'île de molène en
bretagne pour l'heure on s'en fou pour
moi nrj 12
chaque année le changement d'heure est
un sujet de discorde ses partisans d'un
côté ses opposants de l'autre comme ici
en 1988
des manifestations ont lieu un peu
partout en france contre l'heure d'été
pour eux les inconvénients sont nombreux
les enfants dorment le matin en classe
et ne trouve pas le sommeil de soir
quant aux agriculteurs il n'arrive pas à
plier leurs animaux à ce nouveau rythme
même les politiques s'y mettent
certains veulent en finir avec le
changement d'heure c'est le cas de la
députée ps ségolène royal
en 1990 on s'est trompé en ne remettant
pas en cause plutôt qu' en 76 ça faisait
des économies d'énergie puisque ont
apporté du fioul
mais depuis quatre cinq ans on sait très
bien qui a plus d'économie de devises et
donc on aurait dû avoir le courage de
remettre ça en cause
al'inverse des français défendent la
mesure comme ici à paris en 1997
le fait d'avoir de la lumière naturelle
en fin de journée un moment il ya
beaucoup de trafic sur la route plutôt
qu'un 5 heures du matin à grand monde
permet d'éviter des accidents et
notamment des accidents dans les
victimes sont non pas des automobilistes
mais les piétons ou les deux roues donc
à cet égard à l'heure d'été sauvent des
vies pour toujours en 1997 le
gouvernement tente d'en finir avec le
changement d'heure un rapport
parlementaire est remis à l'europe exige
de conserver uniquement leurs divers
réponse des partenaires européens ne
rend pas dit non il faut dire que
l'hexagone était seul à faire cette
proposition
aujourd'hui plus de 40 ans après son
lancement le changement d'heure est
toujours controversé
84% des français sont pour sa
suppression
selon une consultation en ligne réalisée
en février 2019
[Musique]